Why are people pausing "The Lord of
the Rings" to watch someone break a
toe or get their finger bitten
off? Keep watching to find out!
As the town that serves as home to Frodo and
Bilbo Baggins, Hobbiton is the quintessential
ideal of a quiet locale where any hobbit would
love to live. Author J.R.R. Tolkien based the
fictional village on the beauty and tranquility of
the English countryside, and it's where the tale
truly begins. The description of Hobbiton in the
novels not only gives readers a sense of what life
is like for a hobbit, but has made generations of
fans yearn for their own cozy little hobbit hole.
Peter Jackson — a superfan of the novels — and the
rest of "The Lord of the Rings" crew knew they had
to find the perfect location to film the Hobbiton
scenes, and they found what they were looking for
in New Zealand. According to the Hobbiton Tours
website, a 1,250-acre farm would eventually become
the Shire. The website also states that it took
over nine months of construction to build the
hobbit village, with the film crew actually
receiving help from the New Zealand Army.
The result of the filmmakers' hard work paid off
in the final cut of the film. At the beginning of
"The Fellowship of the Ring," we see Frodo and
Gandalf riding in a carriage down the pastoral
streets of Hobbiton, and for those who've read the
books, it feels like the pages of the novels come
to life. In 2002, guided tours were made available
for anyone to come and visit the set, and after
Jackson rebuilt the set in 2009 for "The Hobbit,"
the site became a permanent tourist destination.
After his unforgettable 111th birthday
celebration, Bilbo makes preparations
to leave Hobbiton for good. Although it
proves to be an immense struggle for him,
Bilbo manages to leave the
One Ring behind with Frodo,
along with most of his belongings and the deed
to his home, Bag End. At Gandalf's direction,
Frodo keeps the ring "secret" and "safe," even
though he has no idea of the true power it holds.
Gandalf, having his suspicions,
leaves the Shire to find out what he
can about Bilbo's mysterious ring.
When he returns, he is haggard and disturbed,
not the calm and collected wizard he once was.
Frodo hands over the ring, only to be surprised
by Gandalf throwing it into the fireplace.
What follows is, perhaps, one of the
most recognizable shots in the trilogy.
Gandalf takes the ring out of the
fire and places it in Frodo's hand,
assuring the hobbit that it is
"quite cool." Moments later,
writing appears across the band, which Gandalf
ominously translates for Frodo and the audience:
"One ring to rule them all, one ring to find them,
one ring to bring them all and
in the darkness bind them."
Not only is this phrase insanely quotable, but
it establishes what will become the central plot
of the series. The One Ring of Power is an evil
artifact that must be destroyed at all costs,
and poor Frodo is the one to do it. Although
Gandalf hates sending his hobbit friend on such
a dangerous errand, he hopes that Frodo's
bravery and loyalty will get the job done.
As Frodo begins his journey out of the
Shire, he is joined by his loyal friend,
Samwise Gamgee, and later by the mischievous
duo Pippin Took and Merry Brandybuck. Merry and
Pippin literally bump into Sam and Frodo while
on the run from the crotchety Farmer Maggot,
after stealing some of his prized vegetables.
After the four hobbits tumble down a hill, they
gather themselves to their feet just as Frodo
senses a dangerous presence coming down the road.
Frodo frantically commands the others to hide,
and they find the perfect spot
under the roots of a large tree.
The scene is one of the most suspenseful
moments in the movie, with the four hobbits
huddled together in a dank hole teeming with
creepy-crawlies, as the terrifying figure of
the hooded dark rider — one of the dreaded
Ringwraiths — approaches. As the Ringwraith
sniffs out his unseen prey, Frodo almost gives
into temptation and nearly puts on the One Ring.
Luckily for our heroes, the rider is distracted
and passes without discovering their hiding place.
It's a wake-up call for the hobbits that there are
great dangers waiting for them outside the Shire.
Although Tolkein's work is held in high esteem,
the unfortunate truth is that there is a
sad lack of female presence in his novels. To
make up for this, the writers of "The Lord of
the Rings" film trilogy expanded the role of
an underutilized character from the novels:
Arwen Evenstar. The writers gave
Arwen a much larger part in the films,
sometimes adding her into scenes from
which she was absent in the books.
In "The Fellowship of the Ring,"
the hobbits' harrowing ordeal on
Weathertop results in Frodo being stabbed by
a Morgul blade — which, if left untreated,
will turn Frodo into a shadow of
himself, not unlike the Ringwraiths.
Luckily, Arwen [AR-wen] comes upon the group and
insists on taking Frodo to her father, Elrond,
to get healed before it's too late. What
follows is a tension-fueled chase scene,
with Arwen riding as fast as she can with Frodo
in tow, and the Nazgul hot on their heels.
The chase comes to a climax when Arwen and
Frodo cross the river that forms the border
of the elven lands. In a show of great
courage, Arwen challenges the riders:
"If you want him, come and claim him!"
It's tough not to be impressed by Arwen's heroism
in that moment, especially for a character who
was essentially wasted in the original novels.
She then conjures up a great wave to wash away
the enemies. This scene is truly memorable —
not only for the impressive special effects,
but also for the way it establishes
Arwen's character in the films.
One does not simply rewatch the "council of
Elrond" scene in "The Fellowship of the Ring"
without pausing at the exact moment
that Boromir makes his iconic pose.
You know the one — he's looking very serious
and holding up his hand with his fingers forming
a circle, indicating the Eye of Sauron.
Meanwhile, the audience is picturing their
own fill-in-the-blank text
superimposed over the image.
In the very slim chance that you are in the
dark on this one, the "One Does Not Simply"
meme was a popular fad that spammed the internet
for several years starting in 2004, in which
someone would start a phrase with "One does not
simply," and then finish the thought accordingly.
It's also refreshing to note that
the actor himself, Sean Bean,
is very aware of the meme
and finds it quite amusing.
In fact, he once told Radio Times magazine that he
thinks the memes featuring his face will be his,
quote, "unintended legacy," and he
seems to be totally on board with it.
As the wizard to end all wizards, Gandalf
the Grey is the epitome of wisdom, power,
and kindness. He acts as a guide and mentor to
those who follow him, yet he is also a loyal
friend, and a fearsome fighter that any
good guy is lucky to have on their side.
Perhaps the most spectacular scene in "The
Fellowship of the Ring" is Gandalf's face-off
against the Balrog in the Mines of Moria.
Not only are the special effects for the
creature itself awe-inspiring, but we get to
see Gandalf looking like an incredible badass.
"You shall not pass!"
Just as we cheer for Gandalf while
he holds back the monstrous foe,
so we weep for him when he falls into the
depths below. No one can forget the image
of Gandalf clinging to the edge of the rock
before his final counsel for the fellowship:
"Fly, you fools!"
Even those who knew Gandalf would return in the
second film couldn't help but feel something akin
to grief at his loss. For the ones for whom
Gandalf's fall came as a complete surprise,
you probably had to press pause on your remote
to ask yourself what the heck just happened.
Though he mostly appears in the first
film of "The Lord of the Rings" trilogy,
the character of Boromir had a surprising
impact on the series as a whole.
Part of that is likely due to the superb
performance of actor Sean Bean, yet it can
also be attributed to the writing team's careful
consideration of the character's development.
It could easily be misconstrued that Boromir is
a bad guy, when in fact he is much more complex
than that. In truth, he is a man desperate
to save his people, and that desperation
is a weakness that the One Ring seeks to exploit.
When Boromir tries to take the ring from Frodo by
force in the third act of "The Fellowship of
the Ring," he immediately recognizes his error
and attempts to compensate by doing what
he was meant to do: protect the innocent.
Sadly, Boromir finds death in a hail of arrows
while defending Merry and Pippin during an attack.
With his dying words, he confesses his faults
to Aragorn, while pledging his final allegiance
to the true king of Gondor. The heartbreaking
scene is enough to bring a tear to anyone's eye,
and might have you reaching for the
pause button so you can compose yourself.
"I would have followed you, my
brother. My captain. My King!"
In "The Two Towers," Aragorn, Legolas,
and Gimli are tracking a pack of orcs who have
kidnapped their friends, Merry and Pippin.
During their search, they come upon a group of
soldiers led by Eomer. Eomer informs the trio
that he and his soldiers recently ambushed
a group of orcs, but left no survivors.
When Aragorn and the others find the remains
of the orc horde, they find no trace of their
hobbit companions. Believing the halflings
may be dead, Aragorn lashes out by kicking
a nearby orc helmet and screaming as he falls
to his knees. While the kick was in the script,
the scream was not, and that's because actor
Viggo Mortensen broke his toe in that take.
Yet instead of asking for the director to cut,
Mortensen used his physical pain to express
the torment his character was feeling
in the moment. Talk about method acting!
One of the most beloved characters in the trilogy,
Gollum is a creature somehow both detestable and
highly sympathetic. After being in possession of
the One Ring for many years, the hobbit-like being
once known as Smeagol has become an emaciated husk
who lives only to hold his "precious" once more.
Under layers of hatred and greed,
though, there is still the person
who was once Smeagol, and Frodo's compassion
allows Smeagol to appear through the cracks.
Where Gollum is suspicious and filled with rancor,
Smeagol is trusting and eager to please. In one of
the most memorable Gollum scenes, we see the two
sides of the character arguing with one another as
if they were two separate personalities
— and indeed, in many ways, they are.
The scene was shot brilliantly by director
Jackson in a two-camera setup, with motion
capture performer Andy Serkis giving a magnificent
depiction of the dual nature of the character.
The audience really feels as if they are
seeing a conversation between two people,
and it's a scene worth pausing to
take in the sheer genius of it all.
The monumental Battle of Helm's Deep is
inarguably the highlight of "The Two Towers."
Taking up 39 minutes of the movie's total
three-hour runtime, there are plenty of
moments in the action-packed sequence for
audiences to focus on. However, there is
one bit in particular that not only adds to the
excitement, but gets a big laugh from viewers.
You may remember the escape in "The Fellowship
of the Ring," in which our heroes run for their
lives in the ruins of Moria. At one point,
Aragorn helps Sam get across a crumbling
staircase by throwing him through the air
to be caught by Boromir on the other side.
However, Gimli proudly refuses the ranger's
help, firmly stating: "Nobody tosses a dwarf!"
During the peak of the Helm's Deep battle,
Gimli and Aragorn make their way to a bridge
overflowing with enemy soldiers
trying to break into the fortress.
To get across the gap between the
bridge and the stairs at the outer wall,
Gimli reluctantly offers the only solution.
Under his breath, he tells Aragorn that the
ranger will have to toss him across the
gap to get to the bridge. Aragorn agrees,
although the dwarf first makes him promise not to
tell Legolas. He does have his pride, after all.
Gimli's stocky figure being
thrown through the air,
landing triumphantly and hacking away at the
orcs is not only an awesome sight to see,
but a hilarious callback to the first film's
joke that's definitely worth watching again.
Pippin sings for Denethor
Throughout the first two
"Lord of the Rings" films,
the hobbits Merry and Pippin are rarely
seen apart — which made it all the more
shocking when the two were separated in
the third entry, "The Return of the King."
After Pippin makes the mistake of revealing
himself to Sauron through the mystical Palantir,
Gandalf takes him to Minas Tirith,
the capital city of Gondor.
There, Pippin swears himself into the
service of the city's steward, Denethor.
Though his hope is that he might make up for
his grave mistake by doing something noble,
Pippin finds that Denethor is not the ideal
mentor. A man filled with bitterness over the loss
of his son Boromir, Denethor would rather give
into despair than fight for the hope of mankind.
As the soldiers of Gondor go off to battle,
Denethor skulks in his grand hall with Pippin
at his side. The steward requests that Pippin
sing a song for him, and though the hobbit is
clearly not in the mood for a lively tune, he
obliges. As Pippin's voice echoes through the
halls, we see the men of Gondor ride into a
hopeless battle that will seal their doom.
It's a truly haunting moment, and Boyd's beautiful
vocals are the perfect addition to the scene.
The song he sings is one of sorrow and
grief, and it will never leave your head
(sadly, neither will the disturbing image
of Denethor biting into a cherry tomato).
Though Helm's Deep is one of the most memorable
battle sequences in "The Lord of the Rings"
trilogy, the Battle of Pelennor Fields from
"The Return of the King" perhaps holds the most
significance. It turns the tide of the War
of the Ring, and gives the good people of
Middle-earth the upper hand against Sauron's
forces. While there are plenty of triumphant
moments during this epic battle, there
is one that stands out above the rest.
Eowyn, the shield-maiden of Rohan, has
dealt with misogyny all of her life.
While she is expected to be happy in
her gilded cage at Theoden's court,
all she ever wanted was to fight for the people
she loves. She finally gets her chance when she
disguises herself in armor and rides with the
army, along with her new hobbit friend, Merry.
Eowyn's time to shine comes when she faces off
against the dreaded Witch King on the battlefield.
As the leader of the Nazgul taunts
that he cannot be killed by any man,
Eowyn removes her helmet, declaring:
"I am no man."
She then offers the killing blow that
destroys the Witch King once and for all,
and gives fans one of the most
victorious moments in the trilogy.
"The Return of the King" features a
dramatic climax that culminates within
the perilous realm of Mordor. After traversing the
treacherous plains, escaping the clutches of orcs,
and ascending the volcanic Mount Doom, Frodo and
Sam find the completion of their quest close at
hand. All of their struggles and suffering will
soon come to a conclusion — one way or the other.
As they enter into the heart of Mount Doom,
Frodo hesitates at the edge of the fiery abyss.
Much to the horror of his loyal companion — and
the audience — Frodo has a sudden change of heart.
Instead of destroying the ring,
he decides to claim it as his own,
placing it on his finger and making
himself invisible. All seems lost,
until the vengeful creature known as Gollum
interferes. Determined to get to the One Ring,
Gollum attacks the invisible Frodo and
bites off the finger wearing the ring.
As any "Lord of the Rings" fan will tell you,
Gollum inadvertently becomes the hero of the
story at that moment. Back in "The Fellowship of
the Ring," it was Gandalf himself that predicted
Gollum would have a big part to play. Tragically,
however, Gollum meets his demise when he plummets
into the lava pit below, still clinging to
his beloved treasure. The vision of Gollum
sinking into the fiery liquid, followed by the One
Ring, is one that will live forever in our minds.
After the One Ring is destroyed in "The
Return of the King," the audience can
finally breathe a collective sigh
of relief. Sauron is defeated,
the remaining fellowship has been reunited,
and all is once again well in Middle-earth.
Now it's time for Aragorn to finally take
his place as the rightful King of Gondor.
The coronation scene is one of both celebration
and solemnity. Everyone has gathered to see the
crowning of Aragorn, their heroic leader and
faithful friend. As the crowd of subjects
bow and make way for their new king, Aragorn
reaches the line of the four hobbits: Frodo,
Sam, Pippin, and Merry. Yet when the halflings
begin bowing to him, Aragorn protests, insisting
"You bow to no one."
The new king then kneels before them and bows his
head, and the massive crowd follows his example.
The sight of so many kneeling before the humble
hobbits is enough to make anyone gasp in awe,
as well as bring a tear to your eye. These
four characters have come a very long way
from their simple life in the Shire. Each
of them has demonstrated his bravery and
resilience in the face of impossible
odds, and came out forever changed.
This relevant moment reminds us of the most
important theme of "The Lord of the Rings"
trilogy: anyone — no matter their size or
stature — is capable of doing great things.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.